[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau studio de TV
78 et on valide au gré en parlant très
très belle adversaire les 30 ans du
Théâtre de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
avec Lionel Messi à bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le directeur le redirecteur je veux
dire
depuis bientôt 10 ans pas tout à 9 ans
et demi
alors on va on va parler de ces 30 ans
il faut dire tout de suite que quand on
dit 30 ans du théâtre c'est les 30 ans
du bâtiment c'est d'être en forme d'un
bâtiment qui abrite à la fois le théâtre
de Saint-Quentin le numède c'est à dire
le musée de la de la ville et puis la
médiathèque du canal parce que le
théâtre lui préexistait à ce bâtiment et
il a été labellisé scène nationale en 91
quand le label de cette nationale et est
sorti a été sorti par le ministère de la
de la culture voilà donc deux ans avant
la scène nationale était au pollen
l'actuel prisme Élancourt c'est ça oui
il a été je crois inaugueux en 93 ouais
en septembre 93 par le préfet irignac
des Yvelines encore c'est d'avoir le
destin tragique qu'on sait alors on va
on va revisiter tout ça avec beaucoup
d'images avec des archives mais d'abord
parce qu'il y a eu samedi
des spectacles pour les pour les 30 ans
et Gabriel Gontier était sur place et
puis elle a demandé justement au
spectateur qui était là pourquoi et
comment où est-ce qu'ils étaient
attachés à ce théâtre et voilà leur
réponse je viens depuis l'ouverture et
donc depuis oui depuis très longtemps et
on vient 25 à 30 fois par an je suis
abonnée et je viens très très souvent en
plein de concerts différents
qui est l'avantage c'est qu'il y a une
programmation très
très diverses donc on peut tester plein
de choses voilà la danse la musique du
théâtre je suis fidèle au théâtre de
Saint-Quentin oui pour sa programmation
diverses
toute catégorie confondues en plus on a
pas le déplacement à faire enfin quand
on est quand on est sur 50 ans on part
une demi-heure avant le spectacle on n'a
pas les bouchons on a enfin c'est un
vrai un vrai luxe le théâtre de
Saint-Quentin propose beaucoup de danses
et c'est vrai qu'en fonction des
différentes villes les théâtres sont
plus axés sur un domaine ou l'autre donc
ça permet d'avoir un panel de
proposition quand on a goûté à la
création au théâtre ce théâtre je crois
qu'on peut plus s'en passer on
s'aperçoit aussi que les parents amènent
leurs enfants ça c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez plus soufflant et
puis c'est un lieu de rencontre c'est ça
qui est aussi intéressant je pense que
c'est très important d'avoir un théâtre
de ce niveau là
au tout départ et ça a été difficile de
le lancer tout le monde n'était pas
d'accord pour avoir atteinte comme ça et
bon mais c'est une très bonne chose quoi
moi ce que j'adore c'est l'architecture
du bâtiment donc j'avoue je suis très
très intéressant par par cette
architecture je sais qui l'architecte là
tu
sais stade d'islas Fischer qui était là
d'ailleurs samedi dernier qui m'a fait
le grand plaisir de venir il a 86 ans 86
ans qui nous a fait le grand plaisir de
venir en fait on l'avait invité aussi
parce que c'était important quand il y a
des travaux qui sont lancés dans un
théâtre j'imagine qu'on va en parler
peut-être tout à l'heure c'est aussi
important que ces travaux ne soient pas
une négation du passé et là je crois que
sa présence était importante c'est un
des plus que symbolique parce que c'est
un des bâtiments moi quand je suis
arrivé quand j'étais nommé au théâtre la
première semaine donc j'ai fait la
grande visite avec notre cher directeur
technique et après cette visite il y
avait certaines choses que je comprenais
pas forcément dans le dans le bâtiment
des choix architecturaux j'ai donc
forcément qui entre pas qui ne font que
passer quel marqueur est-ce pour la
ville quelle est sa place dans le tissu
urbain il y a plein de questions comme
ça qui doit être prises en ligne de
compte par un architecte donc et puis à
l'époque je crois que c'est ce que
faisait remarquer une des personnes qui
a été qui a été interviewé c'est que
c'était un pari c'est Paris ce bâtiment
d'agglomération nouvelle fasse ce pari
de construire un lieu consacré là encore
à l'art et la culture sous toutes ses
formes puisqu'il y a également une
bibliothèque à un musée au bout de la
venue du centre une des avenues qui
allait être les plus fréquentées de 51
en Yvelines c'était un pari donc à la
fois ce que je disais samedi c'est que
je pense qu'il faut il faut être assez
admiratif des de ceux qui ont lancé ce
projet des commanditaires mais aussi de
ceux qui des successeurs des héritiers
qui ont entretenu ce théâtre qui ont
permis à cette ville d'avoir un coeur
artistique et culturel c'était c'était
je crois le plus grand théâtre construit
en Île-de-France
et alors juste un mot on y reviendra
mais c'est vrai qu'on a vu la voilà les
spectateurs qui étaient là le samedi
pour pour célébrer les 30 ans et il y a
à chaque fois on voit ça mais c'est très
touchant le beaucoup d'attachement quand
même hein de au théâtre est-ce qu'il
passe oui parce que c'est des habitudes
ce monsieur qui disait qu'il venait 25 à
30 fois par saison il y a un certain
nombre de personnes qui viennent très
très régulièrement en fait ce lieu et on
l'a conçu je pense que l'équipe actuels
comme les équipes précédentes l'ont
conçu comme un lieu qui est aussi un
lieu de découverte qui doit être
pratiqué comme tel
et moi je suis toujours après quelques
années de pratique je suis toujours très
étonné enthousiaste et surpris par le
fait que des personnes s'abonnent
prennent 20-25 même si elles en prennent
15 et 50 à 60% des spectacles qui vont
choisir sont des artistes ou des formes
qu'elle ne connaissent que c'est à dire
j'ai une forme
de de curiosité de découverte perte de
saut dans l'inconnu quoi on est là pour
ça
on est là pour des programmations de
prestige bien sûr parce que la scène le
permet ce que vous disiez c'est que
c'est un des plus beaux plateaux
d'Île-de-France des plus belles de la
grande salle mais c'est aussi un lieu
découverte et nous on est tout le temps
on est plusieurs à travailler sur la
programmation et on est tout le temps à
la recherche de jeunes artistes de
renouvellement aussi des générations
sans oublier les anciens qui sont aussi
importants alors on va revenir en 1993
c'était le 27 septembre c'était
l'inauguration du théâtre à l'époque que
la télévision s'appelait TV phil78 il y
avait un fil et bah téléfils 78 était là
d'abord l'écho métallique de percussion
puis ensuite un lieu magique transformé
ou imager son ne semble plus faire qu'un
la place Georges Pompidou exhibé cette
semaine tous ces charmes pour présenter
son théâtre temple des arts gardé par
des acrobates singuliers théâtre dedans
et dehors se bâtiment dessiné par
l'architecte Stanislas ficer s'était
brouée en faisant trembler la ville au
rythme de ses premières respirations une
inauguration sous le signe des arts de
la scène en général une volonté
d'éclectisme clairement affichée par la
direction il y a un public à conquérir
mais ça je dirais que c'est pas propre à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est vrai
partout
il y a un travail de sensibilisation à
faire il y a un travail aussi je dirais
d'apprentissage du plaisir parce que le
plaisir ça s'apprend faut donner un
certain nombre de codes au public pour
apprendre à aimer les choses
plusieurs artistes se sont succédés
comédiens musiciens et danseurs pour
commencer à semer ce plaisir un
spectacle composite avec une mise en
scène faite de tableaux qui préfigurer
la programmation de cette première
saison début des hostilités avec Didi
Bridgewater ce week-end
voilà c'était la naissance
[Musique]
qui était en cravate en cravate
j'ai remarqué aussi que les publics
eux-mêmes étaient en robe de soirée et
en costume pour les années 93
la décision de construire ce théâtre
c'est dans les années 80 que ça se prend
mis évidemment un peu de temps le choix
de l'artiste il y a eu un concours c'est
donc cette statistas Fischer
c'est aussi simple
et donc c'est donc sur la sur la place
Georges Pompidou à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et alors
Stanislas switcher il est revenu il est
venu samedi dernier c'est à dire pour le
30e anniversaire il était déjà revenue
pour le 20e anniversaire et on l'avait
interviewé à ce moment voilà je vous
propose d'écouter
de la technique technologique comme la
grande rampe la grande rampe qui qui
n'oublions pas une rampe qui devrait
servir pour
pouvoir jouer les spectacles sous la
place
de statut que qu'on a prévu
sont pas arrivés c'est génial qu'on
attend toujours des statuts
elles sont toujours ça elles sont
toujours pareil
non je pense je pense qu'il voulait il
voulait qu'il y a une commande publique
peut-être le 1% en fait qui est attribué
à des commandes publiques finalement ça
n'a pas ça n'a pas eu lieu bon d'un
point de vue personnel je pense que plus
mal que c'est que ces statues n'auraient
pas enfin après ça dépend ça dépend des
statistiques mais je trouve que c'est
très bien qu'on soit toujours en attente
quelque chose
je ne sais pas alors c'est une
architecture assez originale il y a un
mélange de classicisme de modernisme
au point de vue au point de vue sale
vous disiez c'est une scène sélectionnée
d'abord il y a beaucoup de place dans la
grande salle il y a 1100 place 1000
places 1038 1038 donc c'est c'est assez
énorme ouais c'est une architecture à ce
qu'il dit lui-même d'ailleurs Fischer 1
il dit que c'est une architecture de
citation c'est comme s'il avait voulu
rendre hommage à tous les maîtres qui
l'ont nourri pendant
dans ses études mais peut aussi pendant
toute sa musique
zéro en passant par le 16e le 16e
italien en passant par la citation les
citations autour de d'Auguste Perret sur
la façade donc là on est au 20e siècle
il y a vraiment il a conçu ça comme une
balade architecturale alors donc on
pense que la le lieu pourrait manquer de
personnalité ou d'une signature
effectivement beaucoup de grands
architectes veulent avant tout imposer
une signature lui finalement il a signé
pour les autres il a revendiqué
et je trouve que c'est assez beau
qui est une oeuvre collective le théâtre
il y a un auteur il y a des béton
enseignes il y a des comédiens et il a
poussé même cette oeuvre collective sur
la verrière du théâtre sur la façade
chacun des carreaux est très spécifique
puisqu'il y a des initiales différentes
sur chacun des carreaux de la de la
verrière qui entoure le grand escalier
et qui correspondent à tous les ouvriers
et toutes les personnes qui ont
travaillé sur le chantier alors ça va
des ouvriers des élus toutes les
personnes qui ont eu avoir avec ce
chantier et je pense quand il a fait ça
je trouvais ça un tout petit peu démago
quand j'ai vu ça et puis en le
rencontrant je me suis en fait c'est pas
du tout démagogo je pense qu'il y a une
vraie sincérité dans ce dans ce geste
lait dans son approche de l'architecture
alors on parlait des grandes scènes donc
plus de plus de place
il y a une salle plus petite qui fait
quoi 290 places
il y a un foyer il y a un bar il y a
même des logements pour les artistes il
y avait des leçons
peut-être tout à l'heure mais ça fait
partie des spécificités de de la scène
nationale c'est comme directeur c'est
c'est pour ça que c'est un outil
fabuleux quoi
c'est une petite forme qui est pas
exactement mais je reviendrai peut-être
celui qui l'avait conçu au départ mais
en tout cas pour les espaces scéniques
c'est vraiment un outil formidable avec
ça cette grande salle qui permet avec un
plateau qui est absolument formidable
pour la danse ou pour les grandes formes
orchestrales et puis vous avez ce petit
théâtre qui est plus informel de 300
places où là on peut développer des
séries de représentation on peut
installer des artistes pour un temps
donné on peut utiliser cette salle pour
des répétitions parce que le plateau et
lui-même assez grand même si on appelle
ça la petite salle beaucoup de théâtre
se contenteraient de cette petite salle
là donc les espaces uniques sont
absolument formidables alors voilà pour
le pour l'architecture moi que vous ayez
non vous dire parce que je disais je
mettais un bémol non pas sur l'espace
Scénic c'est juste sur les sur les
espaces publics qui sont pas exactement
ce qu'avaient construit l'architecte
puisque au moment de la au moment de la
construction du théâtre
voilà le budget allait être dépassé et
les élus sont aussi comptables des
deniers publics ils ont donc décidé de
modifier un tout petit peu le projet
initial il devait y avoir au départ un
bar sur le le parvis dev s'occuper avec
un bar en restaurant qui se retrouve
finalement en sous-sol et en fait avec
les prochains travaux c'est comme si on
allait remédier à ce manque c'est à dire
à ces espaces de circulation de
restauration de convivialité je crois
même qu'il devait être avancé le théâtre
il devait être avancé à l'absur sur le
sur le parvis oui elle est même un tout
petit peu à l'arrière avec des ateliers
de construction de décor bon maintenant
il y a un immeuble qui est accolé à
l'arrière du théâtre donc les ateliers
ne verra pas tout de suite alors on va
on va passer à la deuxième partie parce
que il y a il y a l'architecture et dans
le théâtre il se passe il se passe des
choses donc cette partie qui est
consacrée à une scène nationale parce
que c'est une scène nationale faut
peut-être dire ce que c'est une scène
nationale alors c'est une scène
nationale c'est d'abord un lieu qui a
plusieurs financeurs en l'occurrence
pour le théâtre de 51 Yvelines il y a
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin il y a
aussi une forte dotation du ministère de
la Culture du département
et puis des ce qu'on appelle des
financements fléchés de la de la région
Île-de-France mais bien entendu ces
financements vont aussi avec un cahier
des charges et des missions cahier des
charges et des missions c'est d'avoir
une programmation pluridisciplinaire qui
soit représentative de du spectacle
vivant aujourd'hui de toutes ces
caractéristiques c'est le soutien aux
artistes c'est la c'est la recherche de
nouveaux publics c'est-à-dire aller dans
des endroits où aller vers des publics
qui ne sont pas forcément familiarisés
avec le spectacle vivant
et puis il y a un travail aussi de
formation
des artistes mais de tous ceux qui vont
être appelés à encadrer par exemple des
groupes scolaires des animateurs etc etc
ceux qui vont être appelés à encadrer la
rencontre avec les artistes donc il y a
toutes ces il y a toutes ces missions là
qui qui sont comprises dans le dans le
cahier des charges des scènes nationales
comment on fait justement pour arriver à
tirer un public large qui
vous le dites t'es pas forcément
familiarisé avec avec la culture enfin
avec la danse avec le théâtre avec la
musique
et on voit quand même que ce public là
vient avec comme vous le disiez souvent
voir des choses qui dont il n'a jamais
entendu parler comment on fait pour
comment on arrive à attirer moi ça m'a
toujours fasciné bah il y a plusieurs il
y a il y a plusieurs façons de le faire
je pense que chaque lieu a à plus ou
moins sa façon de sa façon de procéder
ça va son travail chaque territoire est
très particulier nous il y a trois axes
sur lesquels on agit le premier c'est
qu'on a une programmation familiale qui
est qui est assez développé c'est-à-dire
qu'on a des vraiment des incitations
pour que les enfants et les parents
sortent ensemble c'est-à-dire que tous
les enfants c'est un projet avec nous
peuvent faire bénéficier par an de
tarifs les enfants eux-mêmes les parents
si je peux dire ça c'est un peu ça ce
qui veut dire qu'on a assez peu de
représentations en temps scolaire mais
les représentations les uns en soirée
parce que les enfants lorsqu'ils
viennent du temps scolaire ne sont plus
dans un temps contraint sont plus dans
un temps de plaisir et du coup
d'attention et puis on a envie aussi que
ça que ça rentre dans la dans la dans la
culture familiale cette sortie au
spectacle ensuite il y a les 3000 heures
d'ateliers de projets que l'on mène sur
tout le territoire 5 continents et
yvelinois tout au long de l'année là il
y a vraiment vraiment des collègues qui
sont spécialisés dans ce travail là
c'est à dire qui sont tout le temps sur
le terrain vous jouez enfin vous vous
travaillez beaucoup avec le territoire
quoi on est sur le territoire et je
pense que c'est ça aussi que c'est
beaucoup développé c'est ces derniers
temps et puis le troisième axe c'est que
à côté des 150 représentations qu'on
peut avoir dans les salles du théâtre
soit à Saint-Quentin soit chez des
partenaires on a aussi tout un axe qu'on
appelle le tsqy en balade de spectacles
qui sont légers techniquement et qui
sont faits pour jouer dans plein de
sortir non dédiés au théâtre voilà donc
on tourne on en a une entre 5 chaque
année entre 50 et 100
représentation de spectacle
techniquement léger qui circule dans
toutes les Yvelines alors vous êtes le
quatrième directeur de ce théâtre le
premier on l'a perçu tout à l'heure
c'était donc pierre boutarde qui est
metteur en scène auteur aussi non
également qui a été inspecteur du
ministère de la Culture après son après
son départ de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
qui a
ouvert le théâtre
10 ans et de 93 2003 après il y a eu
Bruno Deschamps
qui restait un peu moins long qui est
impulsé quelque chose de différent par
rapport à Pierre moutarde Bruno
Deschamps il a vraiment fait évoluer la
programmation vers quelque chose c'était
la pleine époque de la danse flamande il
a vraiment rendu cette cette
programmation un peu plus contemporaine
ce qui a déstabilisé un peu les
certainement les publics qui étaient
plus habitués à au classicisme là aussi
entre guillemets des 10 premières années
donc lui il a amené la programmation un
peu ailleurs après il y a eu votre
prédécesseur qui déjà que pour nous
Damien je crois
donc qui a été qui était directeur
important qui est resté aussi neuf ans à
peu près
l'équipe qui a mis en place tout ce
système de relation au public d'aller
vers les publics
qui a fait un travail aussi absolument
formidable et puis vous avez été nommé
en 2014 c'est ça en octobre 2014
comment ça se passe on est vous diriez
lourde avant
au théâtre aussi
et comment ça se passe on candidate
quand il y a un poste il y a un projet
en tout cas c'est des procédures un peu
longues c'est en candidate ici on est
retenu dans cette première candidature
si on a la chance de faire partie des
cinq six retenus on fait un projet de 20
30 pages où on grosso modo en 10 qu'on
va faire qu'elles vont être les les les
voilà les principaux actifs de notre de
notre travail et et après on va défendre
ce projet devant une commission dans
certains membres de membres avec tous
les représentants du conseil
d'administration tous les financeurs du
théâtre et dans les maîtres mots de
votre projet je crois qu'il est la
transmission notamment ouais
transmission et puis il y avait
l'ouverture mais je pense que oui la
question de la question de l'ouverture
c'était l'ouverture à la fois que ce que
ce lieu ne soit pas uniquement un lieu
dédié à l'art pour moi l'art s'inscrit
dans un contexte
social et donc il est important qu'il
n'y ait pas que la parole des artistes
dans ce dans ce cas-là et c'est pour ça
qu'on a fait rentrer les sciences je
pense que
c'est rencontré une cité que vous avez
initié oui parce que sur des sur des
thèmes alors ça c'est formidable parce
que c'est à la fois ça relie des
scientifiques des chercheurs et puis et
des artistes parce que sur les mêmes
thèmes et voilà il peut y avoir la
parole de de ceux qui savent c'est et
puis pour l'homme de ceux qui cherchent
je veux dire de ceux qui sentent
sont pas des chercheurs ils ont une
approche souvent les choses mieux que
les autres oui ils peuvent nous les
faire personnellement mais donc là
c'était important d'avoir ces deux ces
deux paroles sur des mêmes thématiques
ouverture parce que moi je voulais
ouvrir aussi à une jeune génération de
de metteuses émetteurs en scène et de
d'artistes qui me semblait par trois
absents de de la programmation et puis
je voulais aussi cette ouverture sur le
territoire c'est à dire me dire que le
terrain de jeu du théâtre de
Saint-Quentin ce n'est pas uniquement
c'est de ça mais c'est même si
prédécesseur avait déjà développé des
collaborations mais c'est vraiment un
territoire et notre travail c'est d'être
le moteur un des moteurs culturels on
n'est pas le seul
un des moteurs culturels de ce
territoire d'entraîner voilà d'autres
partenariats et d'être présent sur le
sur le terrain alors on parlait tout à
l'heure de de celle nationale de de
service public de la culture et je vous
propose de voir un petit extrait d'un
entretien que j'avais eu avec votre le
nécessaire Jacques porno justement je
l’interroge sur qu'est-ce que c'est le
service public du Théâtre c'est une
scène nationale ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que elle est financée par
l'État pour le ministère de la Culture
et aussi par le collectivités locales
donc en l'occurrence la communauté
d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et le Conseil
général des Yvelines avec un budget qui
est avec un budget qui tourne autour de
3 millions et demi
vous étiez en 2004 à Amiens directeur de
maison de la culture vous avez été viré
à ce moment-là il faut dire ça ça fait
d'ailleurs une polémique assez forte
vous vous en souvenez de ça oui je m'en
souviens bien
c'était c'était quoi pourquoi vous avez
été viré qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous reprochez
l'orientation et un directeur national
c'est quelqu'un qui est nommé sur un
projet c'est à dire qu'il élabore un
projet et le son engagement c'est ce
projet sur lequel il est il est nommé
et en cours de route il y a eu une
divergence sur les orientations voilà la
Maison de la Culture d'Amiens a été
pluridisciplinaire elle avait aussi un
label de production de disques de jazz
et mon passé directeur de festival de
Jazz à la Villette et à banlieue etc me
portait à ça et puis il y a une
divergence disons sur les orientations
et voilà donc du coup je suis parti en
est-ce que la politique intervient aux
faux quand on a une mission culturelle
c'était gym de Robien qui était le maire
d'Amiens qui était
UDF à l'époque enfin
c'est ce que est-ce que l'interférence
avec le pouvoir est quelque chose de
compliqué à gérer quand on a un acteur
culturel ça devrait pas ça devrait pas
puisqu'on est dans le on est dans le
service public de la culture on est avec
des financements publics et justement à
partir du moment où il y a des
financements de différents horizons on
va dire ce qui doit compter ce qui est
ce qui en tout cas à mes yeux compte
c'est la mission de service public qu'on
a qu'on a accompli et on l'accomplit
sans s'occuper des de la couleur
politique des uns des autres et logique
c'est ce qui devrait et c'est ce qui
doit perdurer quoi c'est quoi une
mission de service public justement
alors nous sentir service public c'est
la mise en d'une scène nationale c'est
la programmation la diffusion on va dire
de spectacle existant c'est aussi la
création d'accueillir des résidences de
création vous avez des rides et on en a
beaucoup ici et aider à ce que c'est
création puisse tourner et puis c'est un
travail de formation des publics au sens
très large donc on a une collaboration
avec par exemple une cinquantaine
d'établissements scolaires
de la maternelle à l'université on
travaille avec des associations des
écoles de musique de théâtre et de danse
etc donc ça c'est un aspect non visible
d'une scène nationale mais c'est
extrêmement important et donc la
politique au sens noble du terme
intervient dans ces cas là c'est à dire
que en fonction des moyens dont on
dispose pour réaliser cette mission de
service public on arrive à l'amener à
bien ou pas et c'est vrai qu'ici à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines par exemple
les financement d'État sont bloqués
depuis la création du théâtre depuis 93
donc ça commence à être difficile
d'intervention des autres acteurs les
acteurs sociaux et vous évoquiez
banlieue bleue dont vous êtes un des
créateurs c'était dans Seine-Saint-Denis
festival de musique de jazz notamment
mais avec une connotation sociale quoi
très prononcée mais il y a deux volets
dans le banlieue bleue et je pense que
c'est utopie là doit rester dans tous
les lieux de culture c'est à la fois de
programmer ce qui se fait de mieux sur
le plan artistique et puis de s'investir
à fond justement pour casser les
barrières et faire en sorte que les gens
qui n'ont pas vraiment accès à la
culture dans tous les sens du terme
puisse puisse rentrer c'est ce qu'on
essaye de faire ici ça veut dire que la
culture c'est pas c'est pas seulement
enfin c'est le spectacle c'est
évidemment c'est ce qu'on reçoit mais
c'est plus profond que ça quoi pour moi
c'est c'est d'abord le plus profond qui
compte c'est à dire vraiment le lien
c'est un peu l'utopie de Malraux et de
Villard en fait pour moi on est toujours
dans cette problématique là c'est le
faire en sorte que les barrières ou les
ports ouvertes on va le dire en plus
positif pour que tout le monde puisse
avoir le rapport direct avec l'artiste
la médiation comme disait Malraux
l'éducation c'est bien mais ce qui est
important c'est le rapport direct et
c'est vraiment là-dessus qu'on travaille
et c'est vrai que ça marche on a fait
plein d'expériences ici avec Don
Giovanni avec leur fausse de télémann
l'année dernière vous avez des gamins
qui viennent le samedi soir le vendredi
soir et qui font 3 heures d'opéra et qui
ressortent de là avec ils ont tout
compris ils sont complètement
enthousiastes on peut le faire la
question c'est d'oser le faire en fait
vous pourrez reprendre à peu près ce
qu'il dit ouais ouais je pense qu'on est
assez d'accord
[Musique]
moi j'ai dans les choses dont on a
hérité de Jacques porno il y a les
projets participatifs qui l'a mis en
place ici avant même que ce soit la
Grande-Motte dans beaucoup de dans
beaucoup de lieux et les projets
participatifs ça consiste souvent des
projets vocaux ça consiste à accompagner
300 amateurs enfants adultes on était
vraiment dans l'intergénérationnel
pendant toute une année qui donnait un
concert qui était un concert de création
c'était en général des commandes ou des
commandes aux arrangements ou des
commandes passées à des artistes un
concert dans la grande scène qui fait
totalement partie de la programmation et
donc voilà on voit des envois des des
enfants qui n'ont jamais été en contact
avec l'opéra notamment et si tout d'un
coup se prennent au jeu et font partie
de ce de ce de ce projet là donne tout
ce qu'ils ont et c'est à chaque fois
quelque chose de très très émouvant
c'est très émouvant
la politique je parlais avec lui parce
que bon
est-ce que est-ce que je peux vous poser
question j'ai donc là
est-ce que il faut convaincre quand même
de l'importance de la culture est-ce que
c'est un combat c'est un combat mais ici
comme ailleurs
c'est ben bien sûr c'est un combat qui
quotidien mais je pense que animé des
clubs sportifs c'est exactement le même
combat et certainement pour les mêmes
raisons et ça ça vaut pas tout chacun
défense son secteur c'est avec on est
dans un dans un domaine où
enfin la culture j'aime pas en fait
parler de culture parce que pour moi il
y a pas des personnes qui sont éloignées
de la culture et d'autres qui seraient
dans la culture les cultures sont très
différentes moi je travaille vraiment
dans le spectacle vivant qui est une
partie de la culture et qui n'est pas
qui n'est pas le seul
donc oui pourquoi est-ce que est-ce que
les personnes publiques donne de
l'argent pour financer le spectacle
vivant presque le spectacle vivant
apporte à la société tout simplement un
regard différent une approche différente
de problématique sociale sociétale une
façon différente de regarder le monde et
je pense qu'on en a besoin et je pense
que ce qu'apporte l'art et le spectacle
vivant en général c'est de l'imaginaire
et je pense que s'il y a bien quelque
chose à défendre aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas forcément le spectacle vivant c'est
l'imaginaire en règle générale et c'est
ça que l'on défend au quotidien et
quand on parlait de programmation
Jacques parlé de de programmation moi je
me suis toujours attaché ou on sait
toujours attaché à ce que la
programmation ne soit pas une
programmation dogmatique c'est à dire
que ce soit pas une programmation qui
apporte des réponses à des personnes qui
sont déjà convaincu c'est à dire que ce
que l'on propose dans la programmation
reste sur un point d'interrogation et
que chacun puisse se faire sa propre
opinion me semble quelque chose
d'extrêmement important et pour moi
c'est le rôle du du spectacle disant de
poser des questions à sa manière alors
bien entendu il y a aussi tout l'aspect
Scénic
l'Artist que le l'esthétique qui rentre
en ligne de compte et l'esthétique peut
faire passer plein plein de choses et
sur une scène de théâtre tout a du sens
alors là je vous m'avez lancé donc je
pourrais parler
tout a du sens et je pense que
ce qu'on appelle la formation au
spectacle vivant c'est aussi une
formation du regard quel sens ça que ce
projecteur soit là à tel endroit à tel
moment qu'il s'allume de telle façon
avec telle intensité tout a du sens
c'était check-off qui disait on ne met
pas un fusil chargé sur la scène si
personne ne va s'en servir ce qui veut
dire que tout soit presque et je pense
que c'est en tout cas et ce que l'on est
appelé aujourd'hui à faire au quotidien
quand on écoute la radio quand on va
regarder un film quand on écoute un
homme politique quand on écoute
n'importe qui ou quand on lit un livre
c'est
arriver à décoder ce qui est dit ce qui
est dit entre les lignes je pense
notamment le spectacle vivant sert aussi
à ça ça sert aussi à faire rêver du
plaisir mais tout ça est tout à fait
compatible est-ce qu'il l'exception
française il y a 77 national à peu près
77 aujourd'hui
est-ce que ce que ça se passe à peu près
partout pareil en Europe pareil ou pas
du tout non non quand on parle
d'exception culturelles françaises il y
en a une et elle est réelle elle est
réelle l'Allemagne est très différente
des opéras
il y a des troupes il y a des compagnies
des troupes permanentes ça veut dire que
chaque ville ou
à son théâtre mais avec sa troupe
permanente qui va jouer des pièces
différentes
c'est plus des centralisé
un peu différent voilà mais on est un
des voilà où l'État et le collectivité
publique ça c'est important de le dire
interviennent collectivité territoriale
interviennent le plus pour défendre et
pour porter la culture en tout cas le
théâtre public l'opéra après ça
n'empêche pas qu'il existe aussi du
théâtre
mais c'est vrai que oui il y a cette
exception on peut souvent la question
mais mais vous é répondrai pas
financièrement votre votre action je
sais pas par rapport à un théâtre privé
par exemple chez ben non parce que nous
on a beaucoup d'autres missions que
celle du euh
de faire du spectacle est-ce que disait
Jacques c'est que il y a une partie qui
est visible et invisible qui coûte tout
autant d'argent et qui rapporte quelque
chose qui malheureusement pas palpable
mais qui est pas visible des publics
alors on va feuilleter un peu l'album de
de ces quelques années on va commencer
en 99 c'est un best of c'est Xavier que
je remercie qui qu'il a concocté alors
on va faire comme ça plusieurs périodes
la première période que qu'on va
feuilleter c'est celle qui va de 1990 à
[Musique]
est-ce que vous entendez ce mi écoutez
bien même sans le chanter vous allez
l'entendre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
t'appelle la police alors il part comme
une flèche téléphonique à la caisse
et de faire un boniment
d'un chanteur d'opéra quand il a besoin
de
d'autres spectacles évidemment mais mais
on voit quand même beaucoup de danse
déjà la musique très importante le
cirque aussi c'est
vrai quand on parle du spectre quand on
parle au théâtre alors on se théâtre
généralement mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
pas que non c'est vrai que on appelle ça
un théâtre alors qu'il y a toutes les
comme ça c'est une exception française
oui bien ça avec avec en effet il y a
une chose que vous continuez aussi
beaucoup parce que d'ailleurs comment
choisir des spectacles
il y a l'idée qu'on va programmer pour
un public
oui il y a l'idée qu'on programme pour
des spectateurs qu'on programme pas que
pour nous après faut que ce soit le
spectacle que nous on est on est prêt à
assumer parce qu'il va falloir
[Musique]
à peu près 200 spectacles par 200
spectacle par saison c'est-à-dire quand
on n'est pas au théâtre de 50 ans c'est
qu'on est dans dans d'autres théâtre en
français ailleurs
et puis on a beaucoup de rendez-vous
avec des artistes toute l'année sur les
projets puisque dans une programmation
vous avez ce qui existe c'est à dire ce
qu'on appelle la diffusion des
spectacles qu'on a vu et que l'on
programme l'année suivante et puis vous
avez ce qu'on appelle les créations
il y a et 40% des spectacles qui sont
inscrits sur la plaquette de saison là
j'ai la plaquette de saison nouvelle ici
il y a 30 à 40% des spectacles qui
n'existent pas encore ça qui commence à
exister par exemple feu de Fouad Boussu
qu'on va accueillir en fin de saison
et créer demain et après-demain à la
Biennale internationale de la danse de
Lyon donc lorsque ce sont des artistes
que l'on connaît en qui on a confiance
qui nous parle de leur projet qui nous
le décrivent par le menu même si ça
évolue au fur et au fur et à mesure des
répétitions de la création
c'est aussi notre travail de pouvoir
donner naissance de nous positionner
pour pouvoir donner tendance à des
spectacles lorsqu'une compagnie est sûre
de tourner une fois qu'elle aura créé ce
spectacle
ça la rassure elle ne saute pas dans le
vide alors on va regarder le deuxième
partie de de feuilleter là c'est une
période de 2011 à 2017 donc il y a des
années qui vous concerne dont vous êtes
responsable
[Musique]
c'est donc au jugement de Dieu de
désigner de vainqueur entrer la paix
douce et inquiète
en vrai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le rocher de Gibraltar regardait se
séparer une fille et un garçon
[Musique]
là c'est vrai cette variété de ouais il
y a encore là on voit pas la vérité va
c'est vrai que c'est même à l'intérieur
de chaque discipline de style que voilà
notre travail c'est aussi ça c'est de
montrer l'étendue du spectre du
spectacle vivant mais quand on regarde
ça et puis on va on va se rapprocher des
années les plus récentes dans un instant
mais
c'est vrai que c'est c'est
des perles quoi
[Rires]
c'est vachement intéressant moi je suis
très ému de voir toutes ces images parce
que le spectacle vivant c'est vraiment
le principe de l'éphémère c'est des
choses qui disparaissent et que
finalement au bout d'une saison
qu'est-ce qui j'ai à chaque fois envie
de poser la question en spectateur
qu'est-ce qui vous reste une saison vous
avez vu qu'un spectacles
à Saint-Quentin vous en avez peut-être
vu 30 ailleurs qu'est-ce qui vous reste
de cette saison et puis il y a des voilà
il y a des choses qui reviennent qui
restent mais moi j'aime bien j'aime bien
cette idée de l'effet mère est-ce que
les spectacles sont captés pas tous il y
en a qui loin de l'âme si aujourd'hui
maintenant ils sont captés directement
par les compagnies mais pas forcément à
chaque date qu'elle qu'elles font donc
nous on a des captations régulièrement
mais on doit l'avoir 5 6 par saison pas
beaucoup plus
le dernier best of je remercie encore
exavision pour ce travail de repérage et
de montage alors là on va de 2017-2021
[Musique]
intéressant parce qu'on a perçu les
spectateurs avec les masques
période mais en revanche il y a des
permanences tant que je vois dans
chacune des époques ces projets
participatifs qui absolument on a vu
voilà
le temps que soit en musique ou en danse
j'aime bien mais cette idée de cette
idée de permanence que l'on ne que les
nouvelles directions ne jettent pas tout
ce qui a été fait par les par les
précédentes on est juste locataire de
ces de ces lieux occupants à titre
gracieux pendant quelques temps et on a
vu cette formidable funambuliste aussi
ça aussi c'est
un théâtre mais elle y reviendra
puisqu'elle sera là Johann Humblet que
l'on a vu à la fin au mois de décembre
avec son prochain spectacle c'est une
habitué des traversées en grande hauteur
elle a fait des traversées de 200-300
mètres
à l'extérieur à 20 mètres de hauteur ou
à 30 mètres de haut elle fait également
des spectacles en salle et c'est
intéressant comment elle conjugue ces
deux approches alors je vais pas vous
demander en 8h30 de présence de vos
trois spectacles préférés non non parce
que
peut-être les moments comme ça dont vous
vous souvenez qui restent dans votre
dans votre mémoire bah en fait je
pourrais c'est pas forcément des mais
c'est pas forcément vrai mais c'est des
moments c'est des euh
vous parliez de la funambule d'une
funambule moi je me souviens d'une autre
funambule qu'on a vu à l'image je sais
pas si tu es dans le générique tout à
l'heure
Tatiana avec qui on a fait cette
traversée juste devant tes vaisseaux
sanguine il y a deux ans je crois que
c'était à la sortie du du confinement ça
c'était un moment extraordinaire parce
que c'est un truc dans le type de
montage qu'on avait pas fait ou bien
falaise avec le le
la compagnie de cirque barreau d'evelles
un truc assez incroyable on l'accueille
pendant trois sorts ou quatre soirs le
premier soir il y a 400 personnes en
salle on se dit qu'on va mais
complètement présenter avec ce spectacle
qui coûte très très cher dès le
lendemain et toute la nuit déplaçons
prises et les trois représentations
suivantes
c'est parce que ce spectacle a ému
l'idée qu'on se dise en sortant de la
salle il faut que j'appelle un tel Intel
pour dire absolument pas il loupe ce
spectacle je trouve ça extraordinaire ce
bouche à oreille ou bien encore un
spectacle de Julien Gosselin 4 jours 5
jours de montage un spectacle qui dure
10 heures techniquement c'est quelque
chose d'absolument hallucinant qui à la
fois du théâtre à la fois du cinéma
voilà il y a des moments comme ça qui
reste mais il y a des moments d'une
grande simplicité qui reste aussi ça
peut être un récital de piano ça peut
être bien sûr très simple et l'art ne
dépend pas de la débauche de
voir quand même pas mal d'images comme
ça
alors on en arrive à aujourd'hui oui
parce qu'on a dépassé cette période du
covidiez pour l'instant si vous avez un
peu énervé non non mais comme tout le
monde
j'espère que je vais pas vous le passer
[Rires]
on arrive à cette saison 2023 2024 alors
qui va être évidemment particulière
parce que il y a les travaux qui
commencent en janvier je crois si tout
va bien quand on parle de travaux on est
toujours dans le dans l'hypothétique
dans le conditionnel on va être dans le
théâtre jusqu'au mois de décembre comme
on les d'habitude on est de salles et
puis à partir de janvier prochain on va
se balader dans dans toutes les salles
de 51 en Yvelines voilà je pense qu'on
doit avoir une douzaine de partenaires
là il y a des partenaires avec lesquels
on travaille très régulièrement je pense
à Port Royal musculation la ferme de Bel
et ben ou la batterie aiguillancourt il
y en a d'autres et là on va avoir plein
de nouveaux de nouveaux partenaires donc
c'est une opportunité je pense pour nous
de pouvoir développer tous ces tous ces
partenariats c'est une opportunité pour
le public aussi de pouvoir pratiquer
culturellement artistiquement toute
l'agglomération de symbolique
qu'on favorise si on peut contribuer
d'une façon d'une autre à ce que les
publics voilà pratiquent l'agglomération
c'est super on sera très heureux on va
même aller au-delà de la l'agglomération
on va aller à Londres avec les îles à
couplée au château de Breteuil donc
c'est heureusement qu'on a l'habitude de
voyager vous voyez j'ai léger ça va nous
servir
un mot sur les travaux alors en gros ça
consiste en quoi ça consiste à achever
le travail que Stanislas Fisher mais pas
forcément à sa manière mais avec un
geste
avec un geste plus contemporain l'idée
était de créer un trait d'union entre ce
parvis qui finalement était très peu
utilisé qui était comme un élément de
séparation entre la place Pompidou et le
bâtiment et la façade du théâtre donc
c'est à la faveur du travail que fait
l'agglomération de
réflexion et de restructuration du de ce
qu'on appelle l'hypersentre que on a
proposé le qu'on a proposé qu'on a
commencé à réfléchir à ce projet qu'on
avait dans les cartons depuis quelques
temps parce qu'il manquait ces espaces
de convivialité il manquait ce lien
entre l'espace public l'urbain et ce qui
se passe à l'intérieur du théâtre
d'accord donc là on est sur un projet et
une proposition qui était d'une part la
plus économique d'autre part celle qui
moi me semblait c'est pas moi qui ai
fait le choix mais celle qui me semblait
le plus intéressantes architecture
allemand celle qui était la plus
respectueuse de l'architecture initiale
de stanislasfisher celle qui offre le
plus de modularité aussi et c'est ce qui
nous manquait
d'ailleurs dans une rénovation puisque
je crois que c'est la rue du centre qui
arrive et la place Pompidou
vont changer aussi voilà il y a une
rénovation globale ça va changer
totalement la perception de ce centre et
je suis content que l'agglomération ait
souhaité que que le théâtre nous mais
que le théâtre participe aussi de cette
fasse partie aussi de cette rénovation
de cette nouvelle vision que l'on peut
la voir du de l'hypercentre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ça va changer
beaucoup beaucoup de choses un mot très
rapide parce que justement après cette
émission on va difficile votre
présentation de la saison 2023 2024 vous
avez annoncé vendredi dernier
donc on va on va savoir tout sur la
saison mais si vous deviez retenir deux
ou trois choses sur ce qui vous tiennent
à cœur
question piège parce que
il y a des grands moments comme wine
McGregor qui est un immense chorégraphe
britannique qui est très souvent qui au
répertoire d'ailleurs de l'Opéra de
Paris je pense c'est un des derniers
chorégraphes a donné du fil à retordre
au danseurs de l'Opéra il y a la
recréation de nos spectacles de Michelin
de mai qui s'appelle symphonie héroïque
symphonie héroïka sur la 6e ou troisième
de Beethoven qui a un spectacle 1990 il
va y avoir ce dernier spectacle avant
fermeture le 22 décembre de l'immense
Goran Bregovic donc là je pense que
c'est déjà quasiment c'est déjà
quasiment plein donc ça va être la fête
juste avant la fermeture il y a
pleinement et puis d'autres moments qui
sont un peu plus un peu plus intime je
pense au monde et cristaux qui est un
formidable bijou ou un petit chaperon
rouge qu'on va accueillir bon il y a
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de musique
d'ailleurs beaucoup de musique on va
savoir tout ça on va retrouver et sur
l'antenne sur le site internet
merci merci beaucoup je vous souhaite 30
mai 30 bonnes années à venir ouais merci
beaucoup
théâtre merci beaucoup donc examen pour
les élevages d'archives le montage
n'attend des Idris qui a réalisé cette
émission Paul Berto aussi qui était la
cheville ouvriers aussi de cette
émission merci merci beaucoup Lionel
Messi à vous
[Musique]